- Surgeon Simulator, Amateur Surgeon,
Plague Inc., Bio Inc.
Now comes, Operate Now: Hospital Edition?
You recommended it, I'm about to play it.
Let's get it started.
Bewoop!
In a hospital, every day is
a matter of life and death.
Sounded super dramatic.
Doctor I know you're new here,
but this is no time for niceties.
Niceties?
What's your name, doctor?
This is easy.
Dr. Mike, and I love that
doctor is spelled out.
I don't know if you guys
notice, on all my stuff,
I spell out, well, not on this one, but.
Gaping wound.
Very easy, two minutes.
Okay doctor, we need to make
neat stitches across the wound.
Bam.
God, I like using the pencil for this.
100%.
Let's put the applicator tool.
Good work, doctor.
He's stabilizing, perhaps now
I can introduce myself properly.
I'm Amy.
Dr. Stone told me you were in charge
until he return.
Amy!
Why did no one,
why did no one let me
know about the newcomer
being put in charge?
Patients lives hang on
by a thread and I have to
wait on an amateur to sign
off on my operating room?
God, it's like Grey's Anatomy episode.
You don't have to talk to Dr. Mike
as if they weren't here, Sirona.
What do you say about getting
things running, doctor?
All right, what should
we name the hospital?
What about like,
Happy and Healthy Memorial.
(laughs) That's corny.
Dat Healthy Spot, Yo.
Here you'll find a list of
available tasks such as:
Surgeries, assignments, and more.
Okay.
I gotta build the operating room.
Building different departments will keep
your hospital running
and allow you to produce
the resources that you need.
Okay, I like that, let's go then.
We have a level one
operating room installed,
wow that's a nice operating room.
Dangerous Polyp?
Difficulty very easy.
Okay, doctor.
Now that we have good sanitary
conditions to operate in,
let's see how you perform
a complex surgery.
I don't know of a polyp is
considered a complex surgery,
Oh, but it's in the intestines.
A polyp ectomy.
Any time you have a term in medicine,
where you have ectomy,
that means you're talking it out.
Appendectomy, taking out the appendix.
Polypectomy, taking out the polyp.
You get what I'm saying?
First we need to apply the
anti-septic tool applicator,
which is really true.
This is the first thing that we do.
Then we get the scalpel.
Then, because I have my awesome pencil,
I can just do a perfect
incision right there.
Look at that, it's like I've
been doing this my whole life.
Take too long, or make mistakes
and you'll lose the patient.
Don't stop now.
Scalpel.
Let's go right into.
This is almost like an
exploratory laparotomy,
but it's a little bit deeper than this.
Now we can see the polyp.
Let's laser it.
Oh it's good.
Promote healing by applying
gel over the cauterized area.
Now, let's suture.
Bam.
Look at that.
Good, now let's close her
up while we still have time.
Select the needle tool.
Bop.
And we cleaned it up.
She said my stitching needs work,
but a competent job, I suppose.
I think she's just hating,
that operation was a success.
I'm the man.
By the way, this new game I'm addicted to,
I kinda gave up on Overwatch.
It's called Apex Legends.
If you want me to play
Season 2 Apex Legends,
'cause I'm nasty, drop it
down below in the comments.
Hospital Life, there are
three departments types
for you to manage.
An admission department admits patients.
These indicators tell you
how much cash you have,
how many beds are in use.
Tap on medical departments
to collect the cash that accumulates.
Here, you'll be able to manage your staff
and assign them based on their specialty,
thus allowing your
departments to function.
All right, let's see.
I have one angry surgeon here.
With Sirona assigned
to the operating room,
we'll have steady cash flow.
Let's claim it.
Boom.
What did I earn?
(chuckles) that was exciting.
I got Dr. Ambrosia,
and she gives me 1% extra
money, and 1% extra time?
I don't know what that means.
We'll need a place where
patients can recover safely.
Let's build a ward.
Okay ward, $10,000.
I have 27,000 let's build it right there.
I have 23 beds, and I got another reward.
I got John, the Nurse.
I'm gonna put my nurse in
there, in the recovery area.
Build a break room.
Let's do it.
I still don't get the need for that.
Resource spending should be
solely for better patient care.
Well, Serona, I hate to be
the one to tell you this,
but in order to be more productive,
you need to be well rested.
In order to be well rested,
you need to have some quiet time.
Silence is golden.
We need a break room.
For nurses, for doctors, and residents.
Well, the residents are probably
not gonna get access until
they start complaining
and all that stuff, but you know.
Doubt much resting will take place there.
Those hooligans will turn
it into a frat house.
What hooligans?
We have like three staff in my hospital
that's called, Dat Spot
Where You'll Get Healthy, Yo.
(chuckles) If assigned staff
member runs out of stamina,
the department will stop working.
Refill their stamina, assign
them to the break room
or simply put another non-tired
staff member to work there.
Okay.
Oh my God, I can give him plus 50 energy
by giving him coffee.
Here's some coffee buddy.
And look, my staff is
already performing better,
and we got another reward.
This game has the most
rewards I've ever seen.
Energy drink, recovers 100
stamina points instantly.
There should be a little
thing at the bottom,
but shortens your life just a bit.
Work is relentless.
A patient has come in with
a severe bone fracture.
Care to take a look?
I don't mind taking a look.
Jake, 21, went on a night out.
He fell off his bike riding
home, and broke his right arm.
Ouch.
The scaphoid wrist bone
is usually the most
commonly broken bone when you're falling
on an out stretched hand.
That's the one that's more in your wrist.
This, the area looks like
we're going into, is either
an ulna fracture or a radial fracture.
I'm gonna go ahead and guess ulna.
I don't know why.
I'm just, where it is,
I don't know.
Let's just clean it up.
Let's go.
Bop.
Clean incision.
It's worse than we thought, yeah.
Yeah, let's get the bones outta here.
Good work, I've cleaned the fragments.
Now I need you to reassemble the bones.
Look at that.
Now let's place the metal support.
Bop.
That's called an open reduction
internal fixation procedure.
ORIF.
Basically, open, meaning
we had to cut open
the person's body in
order to make this happen.
And internal fixation
means that we had to put
metal hardware in there
to make the bones stay.
Yay, operation successful!
We could have done it a little faster,
if I wasn't narrating the procedure.
I'm tryin' to teach you how
to do a radial fracture,
or ulna fracture.
I didn't really pay attention.
Not good to say as a doctor.
Dr. Stone, judging by the
hospital's reputation,
the new doctor's certainly
living up to my expectations.
I guess he doesn't know what I named
the hospital, thank God.
Fracture, left leg.
Your patient has a comminuted
break on the tibia, ow!
That's the lower part, the shin bone.
All right, let's do it.
We're gonna start by cleaning, yes.
Then by scalpeling, bam.
Okay, now that we're inside,
the tibia doesn't look so good.
We gotta get these cleaned up,
so let's put them up there.
Thank you.
Okay.
I feel like I'm a real
doctor or something.
(calming music)
This is fun.
Good job Dr. Mike.
I will say, this game
is extremely, accurate,
because I'm legitimately stressed out,
I feel like I have to
deal with PR, bosses,
patients, staff members,
their needs, their training.
I mean, I loved playing
Sims back in the day,
but that was stressful.
What I want you to learn from this is A,
how complicated it is to run hospital.
You have all these things,
you need to constantly upgrade equipment,
make choices, difficult choices,
not put a break room in,
upgrade a break room, give
staff members free coffee,
don't upgrade the caf, I mean.
I prefer Bio Inc. and
Plague Inc. to this one.
I just feel like it's more mischievous,
and I can have more fun
playing those games.
This feels like work.
If you wanna see some more
of my game-playing videos,
click on this playlist
right here, and as always,
stay happy and healthy.
♪ No ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ First sign ♪